[Music]
[Applause]
right down the street
said that Oh run
[Applause]
103 88 in this game Crowder has it's a
call by 30
this is spectacular contact all the way
and somehow able to stretch and get that
ball in clean without using the glass
it's a little more motion and I saw he
was fed up at the beginning of the game
maybe taking a couple of plays he
doesn't use it like that try to loosen
up you want to see him try to loosen up
and get excited
measures
the wine let it play the city game it
coming
they get an impact Leonard peaks of the
cloth hotshot
let it makes its move Leonard the
Elector
Michael I'm in traffic watch this
[Applause]
that jump off third team foul for
Portland Hawai goes
[Applause]
how did he make that straight up all
power oh my goodness hath not seen a lot
of that fits into 2016 in this game to
the flush Kawhi Leonard loves the big
stage
Leonard driving for the way
[Applause]
27 for Russell glitter
[Applause]
[Music]
angry be aware of the inbounder here if
you're filling
it's often ordered to send it by
sentence is this detective
[Applause]
[Music]
fifteen fourth-quarter points by Kawhi
Leonard and 41 points
[Applause]
what up at you boy Adam left go do you
like that content I know you like that
content hit subscribe for more of it
from Bleacher Report